hello everyone and do I have a great
game for you the game was played between
my brother-in-law Gordon Marty and the
legendary Garry Kasparov I was played in
August last year in 2016 Garry Kasparov
came to copper in itzá he came to sign
an agreement about founding a chess
academy there in Kaplan Itza and while
he's there he they decided that he will
play simultaneous exhibition against 15
players Goren March was the one of the
lucky 15 who will get to play in Garry
Kasparov and you know it was it was
quite an interesting game right from the
opening and was a very hard day you know
at the end of August it was like 35
maybe more degrees Celsius and because
part of had to walk around you know
playing 15 players in a circle you know
that that guy is still in shape you know
and it took him like 1 hour and 40
minutes to finish all the games he won
all the games and as it usually is I
mean in regular simultaneous exhibitions
the one who holds it always has the
white pieces on every board so let's see
the game Kasparov has the white pieces
and I did use this photo of him this is
a photo from that simultaneous
exhibition if you fullscreen the video
you can see some people there watching
so you know you can see the images all
you know burned out from the Sun so yeah
there was a very hot day so kick-ass
power plays efore we have E 5 by Gordon
marked each Knight to f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 Kasparov goes for the rule
opus and already Goran tries to surprise
Kasparov by playing Knight G to e7 the
notorious co-ceo defense and this is
something probably often used by players
so when they want to you know trick a
higher rated opponent as a couple of
days ago I showed a game played between
Max dodge you know that obsessive Lerner
he also tried to surprise Magnus Carlsen
by playing IG to e7
but that didn't turn out that well ok
Knight to c3 by Kasparov and a6 kicking
away the Bishop from b5 Bishop to c4 by
Kasparov of course not capturing on c6
you don't want to allow
black to capture with night night
captures in c6 as black already has an
awkwardly awkwardly placed night on e7
so you don't want to let him you know
set it free set it free for nothing and
you don't want to give up the bishop
pair so Bishop to c4 by Kasparov and we
have 9th to g6 now over protecting the
if I've fallen and preparing maybe
Bishop e3 seven maybe Bishop to c5
depending on what white place and here
Kasparov places d3 and d3 isn't the best
move the best move is d4 here in this
position and there's there's a reason to
this by playing d3 Kasparov allows this
move Knight to a5 and now he's losing
the light square bishop so if Gordon
wanted he could have went for this
exchange and this is a very strong light
square bishop so this definitely would
have been the best move but I think as
power played d3 for two reasons he won't
he probably thought that the Goron was
an expert in the co-ceo defense so he
probably didn't want to go for the
mainline and number two he doesn't want
to exchange pieces right right from the
start as he is the stronger player so he
would like to keep pieces on the board
but Knight a5 after d3 definitely would
have been great for black but Boren
continued the game with Bishop to e7 he
didn't want to grab that bishop on c4 so
ok because part of immediately goes for
h4 and now he wants to kick that
awkwardly placed night on g6 D 6 and D 6
is an OK move for black black did have
an option for maybe H 6 or H 5 but there
isn't really and there it really isn't
necessary to stop h 5 so gonna play D 6
and this is perfectly fine because part
of went for H 5 immediately and here
Goran has at least two good options one
one good option is night to f8 and after
h6 g6 and this is this is a perfectly
fine position for black and the other
one after h5 he could have gone for
Knights to h4 now the threat
of course it's Bishop to g4 to pin the
knight on f3 so cuz Paul would have to
exchange a knight captures Bishop
captures and after something like h6g 6
and the Knight to d5 now eyeing that c7
point the thread of courses rook
captures on h4 but after Bishop to e7
this is a perfectly fine position for
black to play but after h5 Boren didn't
play nice to h4 or f8 he played Knight
to f4 and as part of immediately takes
advantage of this this Knight already
played three or four moves as part of
takes it immediately and you know messes
up the black's pawn structure he
captures on f4 and Queen to d2 now cuz
Paro is threatening to capture the f4
pawn and there really isn't a way to
defend it other than maybe Bishop to g5
but you don't wanna you don't want to
give up that Bishop and you're probably
not gonna even be able to save the pawn
so Goran decides to go for active play
he plays Knight to e5 with the idea that
if Knight captures D capture Z now he's
protecting the f4 pawn and this position
is extremely great for black but the
other idea is after 95 what Kasparov
played he did captured upon of course
Queen captures on f4 and now Boren grabs
the bishop on c4 and he messes up Gary's
pawn structure but this is for the price
of a pawn D captures on c4 and the Goron
plays it bishop to f6 we have Knight to
d5 and here go run plays Bishop to e7
why didn't he go for Bishop captures and
v2 that's that's an interesting
variation if you should capture some B
to rugby one now with a temple on the
bishop and now after Bishop comes that
comes back to f6 now kasparov has h6 and
now you can't move the jeep on as your
Bishop will be hanging so something like
castles would have to be played and
after H captures Bishop captures and the
knight to H for this Knight is
threatening to come to f5 white would
have a powerful attack here so after 95
Goren played Bishop to e7 and now we
have h6
Gordon replies with g6 although a much
active a much more active move which
have been g5 for example and after Queen
B 3 something like Bishop to e6 and
Kasparov is better here but it is
somewhat playable for black but but
after after g6 this doesn't really force
white into anything so as part of simply
castles Queen side we have Bishop to e6
and now c5 by Kasparov he wants to open
up the position this is a small
inaccuracy by the world champion but he
of course has to play fast so other
players would have to play fast as well
if I would have been a better move as
after a 5 he's threatening a captures on
d6 and this comes with a threat of
opening up the e-file after playing c5
you're you're still better but now
you're gonna open up the C file after
capturing so Bishop captures on d5 by
Gordon wrote captures on d5 and c6 now
kicking away the rook rook to d3 and
probably again the best move would have
been g5 and after Queen g3 trying trying
something what is much better here but
still g5 would have been would have been
the moved to play but Goran decided to
you know cut all efforts from defending
and the King side if he tried to go for
some activity with Queen to a5 and now
eyeing that a to pawn Kasparov replied C
captures on b6 now threatening to
capture the bishop on e7 and Goran
played Bishop to da
unfortunately Queen captures an a2
doesn't really do anything for black
after D captures on e7 Queen a1 check
King D to Queen a5 check King can simply
go to e2 and the Black has nothing here
nothing to hope for and really nothing
to play here so after C capture Sun b6
Bishop captures Bishop on da and the d7
by Kasparov this comes with check and
already this is very inconvenient for
Goran if King to e7 than Queen to d6 is
checkmate immediately and after the 7
gotten played King to f8
and this is a beautiful position in this
position Kasparov misses a very nice
tactical shot Kasparov in this position
plays King to be one but he had this
before idea after before now Queen
captures on a two is of course nothing
if you capture on before then Queen B 5
is just you know a monster move
threatening the rook on h8 and also
threatening e8 this would have been game
over immediately and even if you don't
capture the pawn for example if Queen to
c7 then simply 5 and black is without a
move so ok
but after King to f8 the white position
is a lot better so the world champion
the former world champion can allow
himself the luxury to play one safe move
King to be 1 so Queen to c5 Goran place
is going to c5 to prepare Queen e7 to
bring the Queen back into the defense d5
now Queen to e7 rook H 2 d1 because part
of doubles up on the D file or up the g8
we have e 6 now of course you can't
capture the pawn is pinned and capturing
with the Queen would result in a very
quick finish after something like Knight
to g5
or rook to e1 you know rook e1 what are
you gonna play here is black you have to
give up the Queen or like white really
has too many options to win here if you
capture upon so f6 was played now Knight
to g5 again the knight can be captured
as the F pawn is pinned f5 was played in
all night to f7 by Kasparov white white
from Gordon is completely tied down here
here he played a5 sort of like a waiting
move to see what Kasparov does Knight
captures on the 8th was played rook
character Sundy 8 and now Queen to c7
what do you do here is black well you
don't really you don't really have a lot
of moves here he played g5 going for
Sonic
mention on the kingside Kasparov played
Queen characters on a5 and here probably
probably the only moves that that
continued the struggle for for for black
are something like Ruby six to be able
to play Rock f6 or maybe be five but
Goran simply played f4 and Kasparov
played Queen to a5 with Czech and in
this position Goran much resigned at the
game as it doesn't matter what he plays
Queen f7 Queen captures f7 is checkmate
and only other legal move is Queen f6
and this also leads the Queen captures
on f6 with checkmate so yeah that's the
game that's that's how how my
brother-in-law faced former world
champion Garry Kasparov and like I said
Kasparov won all 15 games they took him
like 1 hour and 40 minutes and you know
a great day a great day for chess
definitely and you know a great game but
my brother-in-law really tried tried to
revive the cosy of defense and a better
game by Garry Kasparov who played a very
nice game by the cozier against the
co-ceo defense so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon